hello everyone Harry is June hope you
guys are having a wonderful day today
were here with another video and today's
video will be a loop from a thousand
crystal to key chess so if you guys are
not aware crystal keys are a thing
within the game that you can go ahead
and open up chess with this chess that
you open up is called the crystal chess
and is located in the northern part of
falador and upon opening it you're
pretty much guaranteed and uncut
Dragonstone as you guys can see by the
drops on screen practically a lot of
really expensive things however there
supposedly pretty rare now I've done
this in the past and I've uploaded this
as a money-making method because it
definitely is good and right now
uncut dragon stones are the highest
they've been in a while and on top of
that I I'm from all accounts that I can
tell these percentages are off so with
that said we're definitely gonna be able
to make a lot of money and right now I
have a thousand keys and we're going to
see how long this takes me and how much
I'm able to make now with that said
before we go ahead and get on into it I
think it's only right to check what the
price of a crystal key is at the time of
recording so if I go ahead and answer
buy one you guys can see that it is
twenty nine point six K which means in
total basically on the thousand keys
we've spent twenty nine point six
milling this right after the video
crystal keys may have gone up a lot in
price so I would recommend checking the
price before at the end of the video you
guys would get an overall summary as to
how much each key is worth but what I'd
recommend doing is do not buy crystal
keys if they are over that price wait
until they go down they'll eventually
come back down and it'll be pretty quick
because no one's going to be willing to
buy them over the price of which you can
actually get rewards at so with that
said they'll hop back pretty quick but
I'm gonna go ahead show you guys how we
do in inventory and we will get on our
way now overall if I'm taking 12 keys
per trip that means we're gonna have to
do 84 trips now there is going to be
added expenses in the idea that we do
have to buy home teleports for these
things and we also need to buy rings of
dueling to be able to bank so I will
factor in those costs but at this point
I would say we're at pretty much 27 mil
on the dot in regards to money spent now
we are going to go ahead and do the
thousand and see how much we end up with
now while there aren't necessarily any
requirements to be able to open up this
chest I would recommend having ten
construction as that will allow you to
change your home teleport to taverley
and upon doing that you're quite close
to being able to open up the chest now
as you guys can see here I'm just going
to go ahead and show you guys what an
average inventory looks like so if we
price check the keys that's exactly the
price at which they are right now so
we're all its 384 K now if we go and
open up this chest we'll see how much
we're able to make in one inventory now
obviously this isn't going to be an
accurate example as there is a lot of
RNG here but this gives you an idea see
already off the bat the first one is
ruminate bars apparently according to
the wiki rue night bars are a 3.5
percent chance so I mean you know it
seems a little sketchy so in this case
whenever I get runes I haven't all here
to collect them if you don't have it all
you can definitely pick them up and drop
them and try to keep them constantly on
the ground or you can manage them and
walk them to your bank one way or the
other however I will have my alt pick
them up in this case of an inventory we
turned 384 Kay into what seems to be
about 440 to 420 Kay but I'd say 4 or 40
is a pretty good estimate considering we
have a decent amount of ruins there on
the ground as well all right so here we
are finally finished up doing the
thousand keys now this is what I was
able to collect in my alt account this
is one that I had here to kind of pick
up everything that was a little bit too
much for my inventory it allowed me to
bring a couple more keys per trip and
allowed me that you know ease the pain
of having to try to juggle all the ruins
but here is what I picked up so and
total ooh here we do have a decent
amount as you guys can see I'll take out
the teleports but just in stuff that I
was picking up on my Ulta ended up
getting about a mil mostly in ruins
however obviously some in the last final
few chests that I had but definitely
something nice to have if you plan on
doing this method long term alright so
the amount of time that it took me to
actually be able to do these thousand
keys was around one hour and 20 minutes
I currently have a timer up and it says
when I were in 26 minutes but you're
just gonna have to trust me on that
I ran it a little longer while I was
trying to get everything out of my bank
but overall basically it is a really
good method I would imagine and this is
kind of the this is kind of the moment
of truth because a lot of this depends
on how expensive dragon stones are at
the time really the main thing to note
whenever you're checking to see if this
is profitable is notice the difference
between uncut dragon stone prices and
the price of crystal keys really that
margin is dependent on whether or not
it's profitable because it I mean that's
the main return you'll be getting so if
we go ahead and check uncut dragon
stones right now they are down to 21
point 2 K and 20 point 5 even if you
sell them now so basically a lot of this
is going to be dependent on whether or
not I can actually sell them for a
little more yeah so even if I bring
I guess a daily graph so you guys can
kind of see how this is working for the
dragon stones yesterday they were up to
23 K and then apparently a bunch of them
have been dumped down to the market and
that brought their price down to
nineteen point three K but over time as
you guys can see they're kind of
starting to go back up and I think I'm
gonna go ahead and now go to the gym and
then leave these in and we can see how
long or what we might be able to
actually sell these off for really that
entire clip was just a way for me to try
to humble brag and say that I oh my god
go to the gym was what I meant to say
but as you guys can see uncut dragon
stones have finally started to sell
apparently I just bought them at a
really bad time now let's go ahead and
see 21.6 alright so that is really good
21.6 is okay I can definitely work with
that we just just by waiting interest
trying to be patient for a second
overall we just ended up making
ourselves probably about another mil in
total so I'm gonna go to the gym yet
again got to show off as much as I can
and we're definitely going to sell off
this stuff and see how much we made in
the hour and 20 minutes alright and here
we are a little bit later after I got
back so these uncut dragon stones
actually were selling pretty quickly
like I ended up leaving ten minutes
after I recorded that last clip and
within that time I had about thirty sell
now the rest of them did sell for 21.7
km/h 7 would be that they've gone up
they've gone up at least 1.3 k if you're
gonna sell them for the buy price now
for you and to sell them depending on
how many that this person has in as an
offer you could literally have just made
1 mil more in that amount of time there
we go so we hit over 31 male now if we
go ahead and price check it that is 31.6
which means that I was able to make 1
point 9 mil in an hour and 20 minutes
now that's not bad at all when you
consider that the only thing you need
for this method is gold coins it's
literally it you just need enough to be
able to buy however many crystal keys
you want to do so even if you have a
little bit of money you can definitely
take your chances obviously you're
guaranteed a much more guaranteed rate
as you start to go up in the amount that
you're doing basically what this means
is that for each key you're actually
going to be getting a guaranteed return
of 21.5 K and overall the amount of
money that you make on each key add it
on to the uncut seems to be about 10.1
so really if you're ever wondering if
this is profitable what you're going to
want to do is buy an uncut Dragonstone
check the buy price now the buy price is
depending on whether or not you're
willing to wait and sell them it does
take a little bit of time but it's
definitely worth it so if you do sell
them at the buy price right now it's 23k
per Dragonstone so add 10 point 1 k on
to that and that's what you can expect
per chest so that's up to 33 point 1 K
you can see 30 point 5 which means that
you're able to make 2 point 6 K per key
at the moment of recording it's
currently 449 p.m. now if you go ahead
and take the rate at which you can open
which is about 750 chests per hour and
then you multiply that times 2 point 6 K
at the current time it's about 2 mil per
hour however depending on when you do
this it may vary so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this loop from thousand crystal
keys video if you guys did make sure to
leave a like if there's anything you
want to tell me go ahead and comment
down below anything that you want me to
make money making methods on maybe you
have a certain situation that you're in
and you're wondering what's best for you
leave it down below and I'll make sure
to try and get to every one that I can
or at least respond to your comment on
top of that if you enjoy the content
make sure you subscribe to my channel so
you can see it as soon as it goes live
and last time I talked about crystal
keys I got a lot of flack in the
comments because people think I'm just
I'm the sketchy dude that's just trying
to make profit in-game off of like off
of my youtube you know I mean I'm not I
have 50 mil right here it's an hour
before this video is probably gonna go
live and I don't have any crystal keys
in my bank I have well this this one I'm
actually gonna profit Bank off that one
I mean I could insta buy them I guess if
you wanted to think that but I mean
whatever there's nothing I can do other
than to say that I don't have it and
show you my bank I mean at that point
really if you believe me fine if not
there's nothing I can do if you look at
the bank on this account
I haven't cared about cash since I start
my hardcore Ironman so I mean I wouldn't
leave this thing looking like such a
mess so but with that said I really do
appreciate the people that support me in
the comments and actually try to try to
clear my name it definitely is a huge
motivational thing for me so I
definitely appreciate the people I
actually believe in me but before we get
too emotional with this I hope you guys
have a wonderful day and peace